hallo leute ich es wieder einmal panne
und willkommen zu sommerloch nummer 7
begeht adamy bevor wir loslegen muss ich
eine sache klären wie sehen meine haare
aus gibt dem video ein daumen nach oben
wenn ihr spiel ist auch nicht leiden
können ja es klingt noch bescheuerter
wie man es sagt leute es ist soweit ich
habe mir musical geholt und damit bin
ich jetzt offiziell cool und voll im
trend ich bin nicht gut darin selbst tom
ist es besser
frank mein tisch meine treppe meine
besen meine vase dein zuhause mein kopf
und wenn wir schon über social video
reden dann kann ich euch meine ganzen
stalker seiten wirklich empfehlen wäre
mir da noch nicht folgt der sollte das
auf jeden fall nachholen und wer es
nicht tut da kriegt einen klassenbuch
antrag fürs nicht erscheint was ist
eigentlich gerade bei youtube moment ich
muss ganz gut bei mister track gucken ja
hab das buch wieder raus aus dem
gespräch und natürlich gibt es einen
nachfolger wie gelb pablo dass die
gerichte immer dünner werden der content
immer schlechter irgendwann ist doch mal
ein tiefpunkt erreicht wann kommt dieser
tiefpunkt wenn wir weiter graben dann
sind wir irgendwann in china nein das
sind nicht wir das sind die amerikaner
oder wo landen wir den wunsch durch
geograf wenn es jemand weiß schreibt es
die kommentare und west duell ist
eigentlich diese hilfe nie videos die
männer denn nicht vorgeschlagen wer wo
ein komischer als das andere von mir ist
aufgefallen dass es eine
unterhaltungsbranche wohl niemanden gibt
der sich so krass gegenseitig
fertigmachen youtuber gleich danach
kommt natürlich die rapper aber die
machen es wenigstens in einem coolen
distrikt kann man mir lieber zu
richtiger musik und zwar meinem
lieblings europe opel wie wenig man
einfach für ein weiteres video braucht
wird auch ein weiteres video haben
vielleicht eine idee nicht weiter gehen
kann weil ein revival
und immer wenn mein kind dann geht's sag
ich sie geht weiter
es geht weiter da geht man weiße udo
hatten schlechten einfluss also mein
echter lieblingssong zurzeit ist wish
you were here von pink floyd immer den
song hört kann man sich immer wegen
seiner alten liebesschnulze vor
ich bin das passt auch gerade perfekt zu
diesem wetter wechseln und diese
kuscheligen stimmen apropos wetter weg
viele kommentatoren in reykjavik wird es
die kommende woche arschkalt dazu gibt
es öfter mal schauer
hoffentlich hat melina ihre schietwetter
sachen dabei das wetter wurde ihnen
präsentiert von apple kommen wir nun zu
meinen favoriten mein erster favorit ist
das hier
popp 76 diese poppig superpraktisch du
kannst du deine hand reinpacken und dann
so sei wies machen oder es die auf dem
tisch tun hashtag sponsort ich mag die
dinger wirklich mein zweiter favorit ist
schwarztee ohne witz ich habe morgens
angefangen manchmal schwarztee stoff
kaffee zu trinken nicht merke dass es
echt gut ist mein nicht so viel kaffee
trinken und mein dritter favorit sind
die gilmore girls habe es früher als
teenie ab und zu mal gekommen und fand
auch mal ganz cool aber es hat mich nie
so gepackt und jetzt wo ich gesehen habe
dass netflix dieses jahr glaube ich in
der neuen staffel rausbringen habe ich
gedacht okay gibt es noch mal eine
chance guck ich mir nochmal abend und
ich habe viel zu viele folgen denn viel
zu kurzer zeit geguckt momentan habe ich
kein leben kann man jetzt meinen top 3
herbst aktivitäten auf platz drei ist
frisch zusammengefegt es laut treten auf
platz zwei sind warme pullis und auf
platz 111 ps nein das ist keine
menstruation syndrom das ist der
pumpkins peißen latte da schmeckt
wirklich gut kommen wir nun zu der täter
frage ich habe euch auf twitter gebeten
diese lücke auszufüllen der herbst der
herbst der herbst ist da
bei hochwasser und das sind eure
antworten der herbst der herbst der
herbst ist da er bringt blätter auf dem
boden die dann vergangen und stinken bei
hochwasser zerstört meine frisur heiko
waßer er bringt uns beamten zwei platter
er bringt uns schnupfen fieber und magen
darm er geht mir schon auf den sack
heißt hass sei der herbst der herbst der
herbst ist da er beendet das loch haikus
ja der herbst beendet das loch und damit
war es auch das letzte sommerloch für
aber keine panik auf der titanic es geht
bestimmt bald mit einer frischen frisur
geht auf jeden fall weiter wenn ihr
meinen kanal noch nicht abonniert haben
solltet ihr das jetzt auf jeden fall tun
und gibt dem video einen daumen nach
oben falls es euch gefallen hat wir
sehen uns dann beim nächsten mal